she says she became a wife at the age of
14 and was terrorized for years at the
hands of Dances with Wolves actor Nathan
chasing horse eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
breaking stories about the alleged
sexual predator and tonight the woman
whose story busted opened several
investigations is sitting down with
Vanessa first and we do want to warn you
the details in this report are of a
sensitive nature
my name is Coretta Leone she is no
longer Karena chasing horse I'm one of
the victims no longer one of Nathan
chasing horses wives that was my life
that was my life
and he took it from me this is when the
now 25 year old woman first met him at
six years old while her family was going
through a tough time he welcomed her and
her mother with open arms I remember him
walking in and like the way he filled up
the door frame and I remember thinking
like
I remember being in awe of him chasing
horse is an actor mostly known for his
role in Dances with Wolves he's been
traveling throughout the United States
and Canada for at least two decades for
Native ceremonies and powwows he also
claims he's a medicine man and spiritual
leader he has this way of just
making you feel like you're the most
important person in the room when he
talks to you she says he became a father
figure but when she turned 14 that
changed
it's not okay
and what happened there was rape and
there's no other label to put on it she
says when she had gone to chasing horse
to help heal her mother who was sick he
took her into a closet at his home for a
private talk he said okay well the
spirits are are going to come and we're
going to ask them and see what they say
he said her Purity I know he meant my
virginity would be the price and he said
well it's that where she doesn't get
help
that's the last piercing of you
that's the last good thing of you she
says she wanted to save her mother so he
had me take off my maxi dress and lay it
under me
and it happened she says he also gave
her a pill which she later figured out
was Plan B and the sexual assault
continued it happened every night
for at least a month until I was able to
go back home with my mom and then her
ceremony finally happened did you tell
anyone or he said I couldn't he said
that it's a sacred secret between me and
the grandfathers and if I told it would
make her help go away at 14 she says he
privately made her a wife at 16 he asked
her mother who was also part of his
alleged cult known as the circle and her
mom felt it was in honor at 18 she says
she moved in as his seventh wife and
physical and verbal abuse escalated she
says he controlled Where She Went who
she talked to and she recalls moments
like these there would be several times
where I would wake up and he would be
sitting on my bed waiting for me to wake
up to start hitting me again he would
take me to those hotels and blindfold me
and leave me in there and imply other
men would come in and
and I never knew who they were I tried
to kill myself
I didn't see another way out because to
me leaving was never an option because
of my mom
what would happen if I left Corona says
she finally did Escape in late 2021 and
she eventually made this Facebook post
revealing her experience it led to an
investigation by Las Vegas Metro Police
who raided his North Las Vegas home and
arrested him in late January he was
indicted on 19 counts including sex
crimes against Corinna and another woman
to be able to say to my 14 year old self
that something's being done even if
there's no guarantee
but that he was arrested
that he was in custody
that he had to at least present reasons
why he had he has to defend himself
against what happened with you
chasing horses supporters are showing up
in court including his remaining wives
and Men referred to as his helpers while
Karena says she has concerns about her
safety she still faced her alleged
abuser he's evil and he is manipulative
and he is a narcissist
and he knowingly does what he does and
he doesn't have any remorse for it
what he did he knows what he did chasing
horse now also faces federal charges and
there are warrants for him in Montana
and Canada he also has previously been
banned from several native reservations
despite allegations being made against
him multiple times before it appears he
was never arrested until now he was in
the public eye and everyone knew and
said nothing several other women have
reached out to me to say they've also
been victims of Nathan chasing horse or
they know other victims and many of the
stories seem similar targeted during an
especially vulnerable time in their
lives manipulated through spirituality
but there's a fear in coming forward
Karena says she's sharing her story with
us to help Inspire others to come out of
the Shadows I just
I want to encourage them to not be
afraid
because this is bigger and this is
more than just what happened to us
and that this could be helping other
little girls Nathan chasing horse
invoked his right to a speedy trial
which is set for May 1st corena says she
continues to try to cope with the trauma
and repair both the mental and physical
wounds from the man she once believed
she loved while I have the dark moments
and I do
struggle with it at the end of the day
my unhappiest day out is still better
than my happiest day in there Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now